-Performing
"Tropic Morning News"
from their upcoming album,
"First Two Pages
Of Frankenstein,"
give it up for The National!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I wasn't starting yet ♪
♪ I didn't even think
you were listening ♪
♪ I wasn't ready at all ♪
♪ To say anything
about anything interesting ♪
♪ It's a thing you have ♪
♪ You just don't know
that you do it ♪
♪ You wait around
in a conversation ♪
♪ While I get in and
start stumbling through it ♪
♪ I was so distracted then ♪
♪ I didn't have it straight
in my head ♪
♪ I didn't have my face on yet
or the role or the feel ♪
♪ Of where I was going
with it all ♪
♪ I was suffering more
than I let on ♪
♪ The tropic morning news
was on ♪
♪ There's nothing stopping me
now ♪
♪ From saying
all the painful parts out loud ♪
♪ Got to my feet ♪
♪ Feeling that
I'd let you down ♪
♪ I wanted to say it slow
and perfect ♪
♪ But it all somehow got
switched around ♪
♪ Something went off
on its own ♪
♪ My dumb, automatic chit-chat ♪
♪ It's not what I meant to say
at all ♪
♪ There's no way you can
attach me to that ♪
♪ Got up to seize the day ♪
♪ With my head in my hands
feeling strange ♪
♪ When all my thinking
got mangled ♪
♪ And I caught myself talking
myself off the ceiling ♪
♪ I was suffering more
than I let on ♪
♪ The tropic morning news
was on ♪
♪ There's nothing stopping me
now ♪
♪ From saying all
the painful parts out loud ♪
♪ Oh, where are all
the moments we'd have? ♪
♪ Oh, where's the brain
we shared? ♪
♪ Something somehow has you
rapidly improving ♪
♪ Oh, what happened to
the wavelength we were on? ♪
♪ Oh, where's
the gravity gone? ♪
♪ Something somehow has you
rapidly improving ♪
[ Guitar solo ]
♪♪
♪ You found the ache
in my argument ♪
♪ You couldn't wait
to get out of it ♪
♪ You found the slush
in my sentiment ♪
♪ You made it sound
so intelligent ♪
♪ You can stop and start
an athlete's heart ♪
♪ How do I feel about it? ♪
♪ I would love to have nothing
to do with it ♪
♪ I would like to move on
and be through with it ♪
♪♪
♪ I'll be over here
lying near the ocean ♪
♪ Making ocean sounds ♪
♪ Maybe you can come over ♪
♪ And work the controls
for a while ♪
♪ I was so distracted then ♪
♪ I didn't have it straight
in my head ♪
♪ I didn't have my face on yet
or the role or the feel ♪
♪ Of where I was going
with it all ♪
♪ I was suffering more
than I let on ♪
♪ The tropic morning news
was on ♪
♪ There's nothing stopping me
now ♪
♪ From saying all the painful
parts out loud ♪
♪ Oh, where are
all the moments we'd have? ♪
♪ Oh, where's the brain
we shared? ♪
♪ Something somehow has you
rapidly improving ♪
♪ Oh, what happened to
the wavelength we were on? ♪
♪ Oh, where's
the gravity gone? ♪
♪ Something somehow has you
rapidly improving ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]